the clark county medical society
alliance is bringing back its annual
spring
fashion show building a healthier and
more forward fashion
thinking southern nevada rocky this
joins us once again at the wind to show
us how this event of it
benefits those living with alzheimer's
it's all about
high fashion and health and during a
time like this that is music
to our ears right behind me is balmon
that is french katoola and just
a preview a little taste of something
that you can actually bid on
for the 20th annual fashion show event
now the fashion show
event is sold out which is great news
right shirley but you can still get
involved with this auction so tell us
what we can bid on
okay so we have this
beautiful baumann bag from our fashion
house this year
we have staycation packages from the
aria
and the wind resort and we have
a lot of handbags so
come on and bid and our link
is at our website at ccmsalv.org
or you can go to our facebook page and
that will be clark county society
medical alliance oh my gosh you don't
need any more incentives than that okay
thank you so much shirley so now that
you mentioned the organization
i want to talk to sherry about it
because you guys do so much for the
community and for health
of southern nevada so let's talk about
what you guys do thank you
well this year as you know our charity
of choice is women's alzheimer's and our
goal
every year is to improve the health and
the lives of southern nevada's here in
clark county it's all through
philanthropy we're 100 volunteer based
organizations
and what are you guys hoping to raise
with this fashion show event and
congratulations on bringing it back in
person obviously
you have to go virtual for a while but
we're back yes we are back and we're so
excited about that
and this year our goal is to raise over
100 000 for
women's alzheimer's and it will stay
right here in las vegas which is
the best that is the best that is the
best now what's the difference between
you know past
past events and this one in particular
really it's the limit on the number of
seats that we're allowed
you know so of course we follow the
governor's orders on that and
and but we are sold out so we're you
know couldn't be more thrilled it's
working for you
it's working it's working you know what
else is working for us i would have to
say these blazers
these beaumont blazers so before we do a
little catwalk i know you wanted to
thank a few people right
oh of course we're uh we want to thank
our presenting sponsor this year
southwest medical associates optum care
and thank you for your generosity and
for all the sponsor thank you so much
and we can still donate for you if
you're not involved in the auction or
the fashion show you can still donate at
your facebook page
yes our facebook page or our website
which
is ccmsalve.org all right
giving back to women's all the time are
you guys ready all right we are rocking
some balm let's go
walk walk walk walk and we will send it
back to you
a little turn